we're asked to factor for TC to the
third power minus five D to the third
power so the first thing that might jump
out at you is that five is a factor of
both of these terms I could rewrite this
as five times eight C to the third power
minus five times D to the third power
and so you could actually factor out a 5
here so factor out of five and so if you
factor out a 5 you get 5 times 8 C to
the third power minus D to the third
power so as you see factoring it really
is just undistributing the five
reversing the distributive property and
when you write it like this you might it
might jump out at you that 8 is a
perfect cube it's 2 to the 3rd power C
to the 3rd power is obviously C to the
third power and then you have D to the
third power so this right here is a
difference of cubes and actually let me
write that explicitly because 8 is the
same thing as 2 to the third power so
you can write this as let me write the 5
out front 5 times this term right over
here can be re-written as 2 C 2 C to the
third power because this 2 to the third
power times C to the third power 8 C to
the third power and then minus D to the
third power minus D to the 3rd power and
so this gives us right over here a
difference of cubes and you can actually
factor out a different factor a
difference of cubes and you may or may
not know the pattern so if I have a to
the third minus B the third this can be
factored as a minus B times a squared
plus a B plus B squared and if you don't
believe me I encourage you to multiply
this out and you will get a to the third
minus B the third you get a bunch of
terms that cancel out so you're only
left with two terms and even though it's
not applicable here it's also good to
know that the sum of cubes the sum of
cubes is also factorable it's factorable
as a plus B times a squared minus a B
plus B
so once again I won't go through the
time multiplying this out but I
encourage you to do so it just takes a
little bit of polynomial multiplication
and you'll be able to figure you'll be
able to prove to yourself that this is
indeed the case now assuming that this
is the case we can just do a little bit
of pattern matching because in this case
our a is to see our a is to C and our B
is D so let me write this a is equal to
2c and our B our B is equal to D our B
is equal to D we have minus B the third
and minus D to the third so B and D must
be the same thing so this part inside
must factor out to let me write my five
open parentheses let me give myself some
space so it's going to factor out into a
minus B so a is - C - C - B which is D
so its factors out as the difference of
the two things that I'm taking the cube
of - C - D times x and now I have a
squared a squared is - C squared - C
squared is the same thing as 4 C squared
a squared let me make that a squared is
equal to 2 C the whole thing squared
which is equal to 4 C squared so it's 4
C squared plus a B plus a times B so
that's going to be 2 C times D so plus 2
C times D times D and then finally plus
B squared and in our case B is D so you
get plus d squared and you're done we
have factored it out it actually could
get rid of one set of parentheses this
can be factored as 5 times 2 C - D times
4 C squared + 2 C D plus d squared and
we are done